14 м року перед усіма нами стояв вибір
або взяти зброю в руки і захищає свій
будинок або бути підставками під кульки та
сидіти вдома на дивані і коли приходить
війна флойду ран тобі вже однаково як
коли виходить улюблене шоу на ю тубі і
скільки грошей тобі заплатили коли ти
сидиш і думаєш чим захистити свою сім'ю
всім захистити свій будинок
чим захистити лавочку біля бабусиного
вдома де ти сидів
дитиною і бовтав ногами тому
чотирнадцятому році у п'ятнадцятому та
шістнадцятому сімнадцятому навіть у
дев'ятнадцятому сотні тисяч чоловіків від 18
до 60 взяли до рук зброю і пішли
захищати україну не його не парламент
україни в тому числі такі як ці коли
на голову прилітає град тобі вже все
одно ти сидиш згадуєш на дні окопа
всі молитви і якісь тільки міг знати
і не знав її стежить не дай боже ляже
хоч одна міна ви обосретеся
[оплески]